if you sold cocaine cowboy in netflix
you see there was a big operation in
miami called operation video canary
operation video canary they arrested
every drug dealer that there was in
miami right
they were all selling graham sounds like
selling woolly who literally like the
producers that i handed him or the
prosecutor said i handed them the keys
to the kingdom they were selling grams
at a disco
for years
my name never came up and i was bringing
in 800 kilos for two years
800 a month
i was making a million to three million
dollars a month
we were doing anywhere between 50 and 80
million dollars a month almost a billion
a year
in 1977 78 money
it's a lot of
a lot of money back then what is life
like at that time
well needless to say
you know it's like like the young
athletes that signed the big country
they broke all their lives i was the
same no different right but
i invested a lot but
i bought jets mansions rolls royces
uh i had every known car you can imagine
and i dated some of the most beautiful
women in america and i said and i and i
wrote a blog that i said i'm 22 years
old i make a million dollars a month
i have mansions jets helicopters
million dollar car and i want to die
and i want to die and see that's the
message that i wanted to get across to a
lot of people i think they did a really
good job in cocaine cowboys because
the thing about it is see patrick i
thought that
once i reached my american dream
which is not what the american dream is
the american dream is the world war ii
generation that worked their butts off
to have a job in a decent retirement one
house they had marriage problem but
divorce was not an option you know they
hated the war like all of us
serving was an honor they'd rather be an
hour earlier than a minute late that's
the american dream our american dream is
just a false is the fact that you you
have this hunger within you and society
is quick to tell you
listen
when you do this you're gonna be happy
when you date this gorgeous model look
at on tv well listen i woke up next to
them they don't look the same in the
magazine as they do when they wake up
out of bed
you're supposed to be happy everybody's
telling you you're god
you know you did a video that i liked a
lot when you talk about how people are
constantly wanting people to like them
you know and it's interesting that we
live in a world that that video you
didn't get as many views as some of the
other
mafia videos when that video had
unbelievable message
to me
it did because it's so true right we're
constantly wanting people to praise us
we want why because we're miserable
and we need affirmation
see and instead of people saying to me
listen george you're the scum of the
earth
no it didn't matter what i did
you're so you know you're the best to
hang out with you're this you're that so
at that time when you're making a
million to three million a month and you
guys are doing a bill a year
uh what does your mom and dad think
you're doing so see that's the thing my
mom did not have no idea what i was
doing did they ever come to your
managers
no they oh yeah but they thought that i
was a legitimate businessman because we
had
we had cattle farms we had business that
they could see we had construction
company i took my fight to columbia a
couple times to see uh the house that i
bought which was a bigger development
that we have built
so they saw that and this is the this is
where the problem comes with sal and
willie
so
my dad is best friends with them with
his father
forever since cuba
uh every day after dinner till they all
died they would visit each other's house
for coffee
[Music]
to me they were like my parents love
them to death well
so salsa i lost uh track what's up
because he they dropped out of high
school i kept on going to college
and
every time my dad went to his parents
house he was like hey tell george to
give me a chance to georgia because of
course my dad being a typical hispanic
he's bragging about his son how his son
is doing so well how his son is driving
our role you know all of this stuff not
knowing really what his son was doing
so
i was afraid they were gonna tell my dad
when i give him a meeting
you know i was afraid that hey
you know let me talk to him because
sooner or later he's gonna spill it and
then you know my parents it would
destroy my parents which eventually did
and it's the greatest regret of the many
regrets that i have
you know people tell you tell me it's
like
don't you miss that life
well
you have a jet i don't shoot something
is mine
of course you miss it you missed the
thing i don't miss it tell me hey do you
miss having a 7 47 i never had one so i
don't know you missed the thing that you
had but the thing is that none of that
gave me the joy
that i have today
because today my joy is not in that
thing my joy is in me
and who i am and who created me so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]